I have an acoustical problem because i
find that the level of the dynamic level
Oh Papa rock concert is so high that I
feel in danger for my years physically
speaking so I try to compensate as I can
and my son Antoine tries to make me a
little less ignorant than I am I had a
high level of resistance when I was
young what I now do consider as a kind
of narrow-minded attitude that our hands
I discovered it too late that in fact
you have the same problems in the pop
for instance or in the rock or in many
music than in the classics danger of the
business the problem of the isolation of
groups that are very creative and that
are not often in the between problems or
the fashion and how it can kill some
expression and so on and so on and more
than all probably relationship with a
success that means with the society in
general so I think that better
understanding of both paths if I can say
so somewhere can help to understand the
whole
mystery
well there are many dimensions that are
comparable for sure the charisma the
presence on stage the commitment the
energy the ability for communication
dimensions of expression understanding
for our era well probably many other
dimensions yes definitely
the so-called classical serious
musicians are supposed to be ambassadors
for what we call our classical serious
culture to transmit to new audiences and
new generations a very rich heritage and
to be witnesses for what happens today
so to be servants for creators and to be
able to participate to the artistic
education for the next generations
one calls classical music or serious
music or all these awful words requires
most of the time a quite high level of
technical training this is the price to
pay somewhere not always if you sing in
a choir for instance with a good
director you can make very good music
sometimes with a less challenging
education than if you want to play a
complex polyphony with a keyboard
instrument but as you said there are
ways to make music without the same
level of discipline and well this is why
we can be thankful to live in a world
with a certain level of tolerance where
many ways of making music or making arts
is accepted and it's visible